six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's see who's calling from the nine to
five area code
caller from nine to five who's there
where are you calling from hi this mean
that is you oh what's up man I love your
show I'm Sean from Concord my question
is between to the 2020 presidential
election okay I believe Bernie Sanders
will run and I think she'll be the
fourth run runner at the start with
primaries we asking a lot of former
corporate Democrats stop taking money
from corporations the argument of course
is that corporate contain donations
corrupt the politicians so I think I
have a pretty solid option offensive
strategy that so the question the people
could ask
Booker and Harris and the others is like
it's you know when you were taking
corporate money were you being corrupted
and if not then why'd you stop taking
the money like do you think this
argument holds water that's a great
question that's a great question I so I
think there's a couple different things
there one is Bernie being the
front-runner he would be my frontrunner
in the sense that I am the he's the the
member of the of the Senate with whom I
am most aligned politically for sure
interestingly some of the early polls
already don't have Bernie in first place
and sometimes not even in second place I
saw an early poll here in Massachusetts
and it was like Biden Warren Bernie or
it was maybe Biden Bernie Warren which
is even more interesting since she's
Elizabeth Warren is the Massachusetts
senator now Massachusetts doesn't
necessarily determine who the country is
going to select but I think that we
already have some polling data which
which points to it's going to be a
contested primary for the Democrats and
it could take a while to figure out who
the nominee is going to be that's number
one number two as far as the pack money
stuff I love the question of if there
was nothing happening that was unsavory
by virtue of you taking PAC money why
did you stop but they're going to have
pretty simple answers to that they'll
say listen I have always been against
that system and I am thrilled
now that we are able to move away from
that funding system
I was never unfairly influence right I
mean they'll come up with talking points
you're not really gonna trim up so I
think it's a great question I just don't
think you're really gonna trick anybody
with it right that makes it I think the
way I look at it is just I mean they
were obviously I didn't also I guess
another question then after that would
be so like Kyle Quincy did this video
where he showed how much money they're
actually getting from contributions from
corporates and it's actually like for
Kamala Harris I think it was like six
percent then for the others was all
smaller most of their money actually
call it comes from large contributions
so do you think that that's kind of like
the next step and kind of getting the
Democratic Party to go in that direction
because Kamala Harris may not take money
let's say from you know 18 or whatever
but she'll start taking money from the
CEO of a TMZ and all those people you
know and that she'll get the large
contributions you think they're still
going to be corrected in that sense well
I think that you're gonna have a much
harder time fighting that unless you
actually just change what the maximum
limit is because there's going to be if
you're Bernie Sanders and you celebrate
that your average contribution is $7.50
that's great but if the if the maximum
that one is allowed to give is $2,000
for example it's going to be
self-defeating for candidates to say I
will not accept donations over a hundred
bucks like that that's gonna be that's
sort of like a unilateral disarmament
the not taking corporate PAC money has a
very particular there's a very clear
line that's drawn between PAC money and
individual donations once you get into
the range of individual donations who's
to say that a 501 dollar donation would
be a corrupting influence but a four
hundred and ninety nine dollar one
wouldn't be because in the end you're
just talking about people and in a way
shouldn't we want a candidate that we
like to be as well-funded as possible so
you get you get into a weird thing so I
think that the only way to really deal
with that is to say the legal limit for
donations is going to be lowered other
than that I think it's going to be
self-defeating for
to say I will not accept donations over
500 bucks or 200 bucks especially
because then they can it's it's I mean
strictly speaking it's against the law
but if they want to donate a thousand
bucks they can just have each of their
kids make the donation or whatever like
that it's III just think it's much
messier I don't think it'll work
right because I I know that hair is like
a lot of the Clinton camp went over to
Harris's campaign and she stopped taking
corporate tax you know PAC money but
it's only 6% of her you know in coming
up I just keep asking myself is she
uncorrupted still like do I believe that
she's uncorrupted and I and I don't know
if I'm on board with that well great
Pamela Harris has made some Kamla Harris
has made made some prosecutorial
decisions as back back in her old role
in California that I've still not seen
good explanation explanations for it
kind of exceeds the scope I'm sorry what
was that oh the movie yes yes okay so
we'll we'll address that at some point I
really appreciate the call I want to get
to a couple other people before we have
to go to break thanks for calling in